اذا هكذا يختار المعسكر الغربي الاصطفاف
بشكل كلي الى جانب اوكرانيا بموافقه
المانيا وامريكا على ارسال دباباتها
الثقيله في خطوه قد تدق ربما اخر مسمار في
نعش المفاوضات مواقف حلفاء اوكرانيا باتت
اكثر وضوحا من خلال ابداء استعداد اكبر في
دعمك عسكريا ما تعتبره موسكو دخولا مباشره
في صراع معها دبابات الالمانيه وابرز
الامريكيه وغيرها قد تكون مجرده ايضا من
صيدا فالاوروبيون والامريكيون عازمون على
ضخ المزيد من الاسلحه للجيش الاوكراني
فبعد الدعم البري يسير حلفاء اوكرانيا الى
التوجه الان نحو الدعم الجوي وعلى غرار
صفقه الدبابات يبدو ان الولايات المتحده
تخطط لارسال مقاتلات اف 16 لاوكرانيا ضمن
سيناريو مشابه لسناري والدبابات وذلك نقلا
عن موقع ديجرايف الموقع افاده بوجود
مؤشرات عن تمهيد لمثل هذا القرار من بينها
زياره طيارين اوكرانيين للولايات المتحده
من اجل التدرب على طائرات افسته عشر وما
يزيد من التكهنات حول ملف المقاتلات هو
اعلان شركه لوكيد مارتن المصنعه للطائرات
عن استعدادها لتلبيه طلبات الامداد
[موسيقى]
هي الدبابه الاقوى في العالم نتحدث عن
دبابات ابرامز التي هي في طريقها الى
اوكرانيا اذا لتحدثان نقله نوعيه حقيقيه
على مستوى العتاد الاوكراني اوكرانيا حبست
انفاسها قبل سماع كلمات الرئيس الامريكي
وهو يعلن ارساله 31 دبابات ابرامز الى
اوكرانيا في قرار لم يكن سهلا بالنسبه لي
بايضا بهذا الخصوص كشفت صحيفه نيورك تايمز
النقاب عن الكواليس التي سبقت اتخاذ هذا
القرار اعلان سبقته مفاوضات مطوله بين
واشنطن وبرلين تحديدا التي كانت بدورها
متردده في ارسال دبابات لكن عوامل عده
غيرت مجرى الاحداث اولها التطورات التي
حدثت على ارض المعركه في ظل التكثيف في
موسكو لحجماتها في الفتره الماضيه ما
اعطاها تفوق النسبيا النقطه الثانيه هي
رغبته في عدم السماح بحدوث شرخ في صفوف
المعسكر الغربي الذي عرف النوعا من التصدع
بسبب ملف الدبابات تحديدا وهو ما اكده
ايضا من خلال قوله اردنا التاكد من اننا
جميعا معا لكن يبدو ان فرنسا ليست معه على
الاقل حتى الان المزيد مع زينه عدي
لا تستبعد باريس تسليم دبابات لوكلير
القتاليه الثقيله لاوكرانيا من اجل دعمها
في الحرب ضد روسيا لكن اتخاذ قرار نهائيا
في ذلك يحتاج وقتا والاسباب عديده واهمها
بان تصميم هذه الدبابه يعتبر معقدا
وعالتكلفه ثم ان عدده هذه الدبابات التي
صنعت محدوده في فرنسا ما يشكل عائقا كبيرا
في حال الحاجه الى صيانتها وتمتلك هيئه
الاركان العامه الفرنسيه اسطولا من
لوكيليب مكونا 226 دبابه وهو عدد محدود
خاصه ان 60% منها فقط جاهزه للاستخدام وما
تبقى يستخدم في التدريبات من باريس عادي
[موسيقى]
لا على الاطلاق من المؤكد ان الدعم
العسكريه لاوكرانيا لن يضعف فرنسا فلديها
ما يكفي من الاسلحه ولن يضعف الدول
الاوروبيه او امريكا
دعم اوكرانيا بالاسلحه بات شعار المرحله
القادمه بالنسبه للغرب فالموضوع بلغ حد
التفكير في انشائي مصانع للاسلحه خصيصا
لتلبيه حاجيات اوكرانيا الفكره اقترحها
رئيس لجنه الدفاع في مجلس العموم
البريطاني طوباس الود وبرر فكرته بتضائل
مخزونات الاسلحه الغربيه فضلا على ان
الفكره ستمنح الجيش الاوكراني استقلاليه
اكبر عروب عبد الحق معها المزيد من
التفاصيل حولها هذا المقطع
انت ماشي مع التحركات الاخيره لدعم
اوكرانيا في مواجهتها العسكريه مع القوات
الروسيه دعا رئيس اللجنه البرلمانيه
المكلفه بشؤون الدفاع الى بناء مصنع
للاسلحه في بولندا كجزء من خطه طويله
الامد لتجهيزه اوكرانيا بالاسلحه والمعدات
العسكريه واعتبر النائب في حزب المحافظين
ترابيس ان تردد الغرب في تزويد اوكرانيا
بالمعدات العسكريه يعكس ضعفا في رؤيه
الاستراتيجيه الغربيه كما ان تجويدها بعدد
محدود من الدبابات امر جيد الا انه ليس
حلا مستداما وفق تعبيره وبحسب قلود فانا
ان شاء الله مصنع للاسلحه في بولندا
سيساعد اوكرانيا في كسب استقلاليه عسكريه
من ناحيه ضمان الامدادات كاشفا ان
المحادثات بدات للفعل مع هولندا لانشائي
مصنع قادر على انتاج دبابات من نوع
الالمانيه والنتيجه حسب تكون تقليل الضغط
الذي يواجهه الغرب لتوفير احت اوكرانيا
وحمايه مخازنها من الاستنجاء
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه يجب ان ندعم اوكرانيا بشكل كبير
نحن ننتمي لعلم واحد ويجب ان نساعد بقدر
ما نستطيع
وكما نعلم فالاسلحه جزء من عالم التجاره
ولا اعلم اذا ما كنا نريد فعلا ان ندعم
ذلك في النزاعات اليوم افضل ان نساعد
الافراد
بشكل كامل ومن كل قلبي ادعمه اوكرانيا فما
تا اناس يدفعون حياتهم ثمنا وهو اقل ما
نستطيع فعله وانا ادعم كل جهود في سبيل
تحقيق ذلك
وسط هذا الخطام يطرح السؤال الكبير كيف
سيتعامل بوتن مع كل هذه التطورات التي
تقوي بشكل كبير موقفه اوكرانيا في الحرب
خطط كثيره لوح بها بوت منذ بدايه تعقد
المعركه غير ان العامل الزمني سيكون هذه
المره حاسما ساموسكو مدعوه الى التعجيل في
تنفيذ خطتها في اسرع وقت ممكن الخيار
الاول هو الاسرع في حل مشكله
التعداد تعداد الجيش الروسي فرقنا قرار
التعبئه الجزئيه فضلا عن الاستنجاد بقوه
جيش الشيشان الا ان الجيش الروسي مطالب
بحشد اعدد اكبر الحل الثاني المتاح في وجه
بوتن هو الاستفاده من الموقع الجغرافي
لحلفته بلا روسيا الجار الشماليه
لاوكرانيا حيث نشرت موسكو قواتها على
ارضها اما الخيار الثالث فهو الذي يبقى
الاصعب والاخضر وهو اللجوء الى السلاح
النووي التكتيكي الذي لوحد به روسيا في
الكثيري من المناسبه